[Music]
I just asked Brianna she's seen a little
[ __ ] she says I don't know what that
is what is it little dick he's a rapper
okay yeah that's what that is
I don't know hey I'm Greg this is
Brianna white from strange rebel gaming
go check out her channel so today we're
gonna watch the little Dicky pillow
talking featuring brain official music
video ten minutes or eleven actually I'm
only do is I love little Dicky but hey
real quick real quick real quick real
quick be really quick have you haven't
seen the last couple videos we recently
launched the patreon I love doing the
patron of the day shoutouts for the
community but I have no more people to
shout out right now so if you want to
get a shout out go check out our patreon
patreon comm slash the real rejects see
what it's all about all we have to offer
in return what some hey let's do this
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
Wow I was epic I'm so impressed I've
seen a few of this guy a little bit
music videos I've never seen anything
like that of his wow scale though like
the visuals were like no word like not
half bad the transitions are great I
just love the whole concept of it how it
starts off like oh this is a sexy rap
song and then they have like this rather
it's pretty graphic for a YouTube video
of a sex yeah wasn't sure it was a
little bit wary of if I was gonna be
okay watching yeah we are not watching
this is friends and then having the
awkward because it's just the scene
we're watching characters lips are
moving and then he's using voices but
you can still very obviously tone that's
him
and and yet still you get so easily
immersed into the story yeah the actual
argument are the obvious cuz at first he
was like and he's like and she's like
and then he dropped all that is him
talking
you can tell yeah it's a great spoof of
like these kind of songs
the pillow talking version because the
way the dialogue played out the rat
played out was great cuz the whole first
half they're like teetering on argument
but they're like the trying to avoid an
argument like let's just write how would
like debate here and talk but no no but
they just can't help but engage in it
and then when he gets all full-blown out
I'm gonna get some more mad as wrapping
gets faster I just love it yeah that was
great I love although crazy like weird
visual transitions yeah dinosaurs john c
reilly started so normal it was like
okay like he's a UFO and then they start
talking about the animals in the the
reversals that he uses and there are
just really really funny wonder how we
got john c reilly to be a part of this
money money girl she was beautiful [ __ ]
that one up yeah she's actually way out
of his league I don't think so yeah you
think she's like way hotter than him I
don't know he's got skill though he's
got talent have you said he wrote this
whole thing that's yeah that's him
rapping no changes the attraction up a
little bit no come on it's pretty he has
some pretty cool rap songs that are
really funny online I'll say this there
are different things that make someone
attractive so just visually if I knew
nothing else about it but how he looked
she's way out of curly hair and beard
but it's it's not to say that that's the
only thing that matters and so they're
saying something about me oh my god
that's exactly my cuz I'm curly hair and
beard too okay well here's something
that I would have liked to see okay I
know that it makes more sense now that
he wrote in so this might be a specific
experience that he so like I get it but
I if if I hadn't known that I still
would have said this I would have liked
to see a little bit more of her being
right and that's not to say I just would
have liked to see a little bit more fair
report a cuz as it kind of get off it
was a little ones
it was like the brain being like this
[ __ ] is stupid right and so it just
portrayed her is a little bit one-sided
a little bit fat which was funny but it
would have been an interesting reversal
if she really called him out on that
complete conspiracy theory about aliens
sure I would have liked to just see a
little bit more fair ground I can I can
agree with that but in terms of like
this is a rap song from the guys
perspective sure I feel like a lot of
rap songs when they're talking [ __ ]
about the girl
that's right always the one side yeah
it's always insulting the girl and only
his perspective primarily in like what I
mean to say that it wouldn't see that I
think it would have just added a little
bit more cuz with a rap battle there's
two perspectives and they're constantly
dissing each other and so I would have
liked to see a little bit more of that
playfulness yeah because I got
competition keep us guessing like oh
who's really the idiot here yeah because
by the end of it she did seem a little
uptight rather naive constantly called
her out for her hypocracy which isn't to
say people like that don't exist male
and female they totally do who are like
I'm vegetarian and then not wear a
leather purse yeah that exists this is
just a great example of what hot women
are succumb to in media just to be hot I
wasn't gonna say it but it's true you
know it's true you don't play games on
your channel that's all you do you don't
even have a controller someone's
controlling that for you some people
think that about me
maybe you've actually don't play your
yeah Janissary video I've gotten
comments that were like wow the host is
pretty who's the man who wrote oh man
and I'm sure they were well-intentioned
people just wanting to give credit to
the writer but you're looking at I don't
get why they do that with women in the
[ __ ] because I feel like I feel like
so many women I feel I get around you
and I feel like you're a million times
more intelligent than me I feel that way
of like with a lot of women especially
you though my shelter up and I'm like
I'm an idiot but is that their problem
or is that yours that's my problem but
I'm saying I don't support this whole
trailer women I didn't look at this and
go oh my god this is so sexist Yeah
right I didn't watch this and look at
that because I was looking at more
interesting parts of it I just would
have liked to see a little bit more
competition between the two because that
makes for a more interesting viewer
experience of who's gonna win who's
gonna one-up each other it would up the
stakes is also it would have for sure
but for what we got I thought it was
really like this song like it's a song
that I think can be funny to listen to I
think it's especially funny or with the
music video though because when you're
watching when it first starts out you
think you think it's like okay I get
what this is gonna be but then it just
goes [ __ ] batshit and I love that I
love when a sketch just goes crazy and
says featuring brain I don't know if
brain is a character on some other
channel or if he's been on little Dicky
before some his voice I thought was his
voice - yeah separate voice for I don't
know maybe it's just a character but the
brain character was funny brain
character was hilarious yeah I mean I
thought every part of this was over yes
and I think that it's really interesting
that he almost seems to have mixed
genres here he almost wrote dialogue and
then turned it into a pretty much was it
was like rhyming dialogue yeah but at
the same time it was incredibly musical
and it was it did have changing rhythms
and and timecode yeah the other thing it
didn't have was a course yeah a little
bit with brain a little he repeated a
few things but not really recommend me
as to that that's brilliant
I would I would watch five more times
and find new things yeah oh is the
[ __ ] line of the brain said that just
crack me up [ __ ] don't know about was
it was so funny god john c reilly yeah
it makes them I can see john c reilly
being partisan
yeah but I just wonder how they like it
got him to agree to be part of the drunk
history a little bit yeah a little bit
on the weird side it also has the like
talking voices and then an overarching
narrator yeah yeah yeah the visuals on
here I was I was really impressed
actually yeah it was like the dinosaur
effects look great and then because when
they would go from the bedroom into it
yeah I was really [ __ ] me that was
very impressed and I also liked the
beginning of it if you want to talk
about symbolism where it kind of like
looks into the keyhole into the bedroom
yeah no it's what is said behind locked
doors yeah weird [ __ ] you know I love it
pillow talking gone wrong
yes I've had that happen before that's
the worst when you had like passionate
love and then you get into a fight
you've never had that none of those
things you've never even made I'm just a
sponge you just nod your head and say
yes you don't stand up for your own
beliefs I'm just like this God she is a
religious yet she was solely if I'm
being [ __ ] by a random guy he's
totally
I mean it's insinuate but it's nice yeah
no she was a virgin at virgin again I
can't see it that words virgin a
vegetarian make stuff mean I'm a virgin
I'm sorry I want that to be a meme they
just don't know about Pangea oh yeah
what's her name it should be initially
in the description yeah yeah Taylor miss
yok what do you see what do you see on
yeah what currently [ __ ] who don't know
about Panza oh wow is she dating him
oh she's gorgeous she's very pretty
they're shooting I won't order actual
voice sounds like her she's dead Wow
Instagram reactions weird she's gorgeous
though she really is she's gonna go far
it's weird she doesn't look anything
like her pictures on screen her face
almost like
jizz on screen very much a screen
presence she looks kind of like Marnie
from girls but not in her pictures there
I like their voice I think she's
beautiful I will not ask her to
collaborate on the channel tool this
channel is much bigger why because
that's how I roll
asking you shall not receive opposite
after you won't get it God's rules
alright if you guys haven't seen little
Dickie I think so yeah all this songs
were like rap comedies that I've seen I
have seen I've seen like a video where
he's doing interview does like a
freestyle yeah so he can do like legit
rap but I know he's made his name
they're doing like comedy raps alright
guys well hey you can subscribe to the
reject channel notification Bell click
it because you got it now I'm sorry you
just got to do two things
YouTube is broken Brianna white strange
rebel gaming is the channel that she has
awesome Let's Plays on there with this
lovely beautiful face and intelligence
and personality
lovely intelligent personality beautiful
thank you that's yeah that's why the web
rank you yeah yeah there's definitely
more intelligent than you are beautiful
thank you
and I actually do take that as a
compliment
as you should I don't really mind you
should stop now forever safe